This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. By the late 1980s, AIDS had been in the US for almost a decade. If you look through timelines from this period, you see the records of 100 people dead, 1,000 people dead, a million people dead. AIDS becomes the number one killer of young men in New York City, then of young men in the country, then of young men and women in the country. But what you don't see much of in the late 80s is public acknowledgement of AIDS. That's reporter Audrey Quinn.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。到 20世纪 80年代末，艾滋病在美国已经存在了近十年。如果你翻看这一时期的历程记录，你会看到 100人死亡、1000人死亡、一百万人死亡的数字。艾滋病成为纽约市年轻人的头号杀手，然后是全美年轻人的头号杀手，接着是全国年轻男女的头号杀手。但你在 80年代末不太能看到的是对艾滋病的公开承认。那是记者奥黛丽·奎因。
Millions of people were dying of this mysterious new disease, but there was so much stigma against talking about it. You kind of felt like you were living in a war zone and there was no reporting. It was a bizzara world. That's Patrick O'Connell. He was really involved with him in Hattenart scene in the late 80s. A community where it could be hard to think about anything but the AIDS crisis. We would spend days going to St. Vincent to visit someone,
数百万人死于这种神秘的新疾病，但谈论它的污名化太严重了。你有点觉得自己生活在战区，却没有任何报道。那是一个奇异的世界。那是帕特里克·奥康奈尔。他深度参与了 80年代末的曼哈顿艺术圈。这是一个让人很难不去想艾滋病危机的社群。我们会花好几天时间去圣文森特医院探望某人，
going to Redden's for a funeral and then getting on your answering machine, a message of somebody flipping out because they've just been told that they're going to be sick, or are sick. So Patrick and a group of other artists turned their focus to AIDS. Yeah, why were you making art in response to AIDS? Actually, I don't know his death that question. Why would you not be? response dates.
去雷登斯参加葬礼，然后接听你的答话机，听到某个刚被告知自己将要生病或已经生病的人崩溃的留言。因此，帕特里克和一群其他艺术家将他们的焦点转向了艾滋病。是的，你们为什么会创作艺术来回应艾滋病？事实上，我不知道他的死那个问题。你为什么不回应日期呢？
In 1988, O'Connell and his collaborators began calling their collective visual aids. They held public events to raise aids awareness. There were slideshows, gallery shows. But of all the work they did, the thing that had the biggest effect was a simple little symbol. That, at the time, was a novel concept. The AIDS Awareness Ribbon. It all started one night in the spring of 1991. The visual aid artist caucus held a meeting in search of a symbol. They wanted something that could be created that could
1988年，奥康奈尔和他的合作者们开始将他们的集体命名为“视觉艾滋”（Visual AIDS）。他们举办公共活动来提高人们对艾滋病的认识。有幻灯片放映、画廊展览。但在他们所有的工作中，产生最大影响的是一个简单的小符号。在当时，这是一个新颖的概念。艾滋病意识丝带。这一切始于 1991年春天的某个夜晚。“视觉艾滋”艺术家核心小组举行了一次会议，寻找一个符号。他们想要一个可以被创造出来的东西，能够
be put out there for people to wear. That's Mark Hoppe, he's a costume designer and was at that meeting. He's now director of costumes for the New York City Ballet. Back then, he and friends had been doing a lot of driving around upstate New York. This was at the time of the Persian Gulf War. We started to see, of course, at the time, yellow ribbons that were tied around trees, which is, you know, in reference to that song for Service Men. You know, we just were like, hmm, you know, why couldn't we do something like that for AIDS? And we talked about, you know, would it really be around a tree Why couldn't we do something like that for AIDS?
被制作出来让人们佩戴。那是马克·霍佩，他是一名服装设计师，也出席了那场会议。他现在是纽约市芭蕾舞团的服装总监。那时，他和朋友们经常开车去纽约州北部。那是波斯湾战争时期。当然，我们当时开始看到，黄丝带被系在树上，你知道，这是为了呼应那首关于军人的歌。你知道，我们当时就在想，嗯，你知道，为什么我们不能为艾滋病做点这样的事呢？我们讨论了，你知道，它真的会系在树上吗？为什么我们不能为艾滋病做点类似的事情呢？
And we talked about, you know, would it really be around a tree? And that just seemed a little like, I don't know, not right. Then it became like, oh, maybe not around the tree, but maybe folded with a pin on your lapel. Then it was time to pick a color. In the, the meaning it also came about
我们还讨论了，你知道，它真的会系在树上吗？那听起来有点像，我不知道，不太对劲。然后就变成了，哦，也许不是系在树上，而是折叠起来，用别针别在西装翻领上。接下来是选择颜色。在当时的意义中，它也随之产生
that it was like, yes, it should be red because it represents blood. It was just so obviously right. A local ribbon supplier donated schools of half inch wide red, grograin ribbon. Grograins that ribbed ribbon you might have worn around your ponytail growing up. And we started just in these meetings like folding them and doing different things with them. And first it just started out just like folding it in half. But then it came to actually folding it in that way we now know it so well with the safety pin.
那就是它应该是红色的，因为它代表血液。这简直是理所当然的正确。一家本地的丝带供应商捐赠了一卷卷半英寸宽的红色罗缎丝带。罗缎就是你在成长过程中可能扎在马尾辫周围的那种有罗纹的丝带。我们开始在这些会议上把它们折叠起来，用它们做不同的事情。起初它只是像把它对折一样。但后来演变成实际上以我们现在非常熟悉的那种方式用安全别针将它折好。
The looped inverted V shape. We were on the streets of the city within ten weeks or something with them. Patrick O'Connell again. By this time he was director of VisualAids. And at this point the Red Ribbons were essentially an art project. The VisualAids artists caucus members held what they called Ribbon Bees. Think like a quilting bee, a bunch of people gathered to work. They'd hand cut, fold, and pin thousands of ribbons. I'll just a hand out for free.
那个环状的倒 V 形。我们在十周左右的时间里就把它们带到了城市的街道上。又是帕特里克·奥康奈尔。这时候他是“视觉艾滋”的主任。而此时，红丝带本质上是一个艺术项目。“视觉艾滋”艺术家核心小组成员举办了他们所谓的“丝带聚会”（Ribbon Bees）。就像缝纫聚会一样，一群人聚集在一起工作。他们手工切割、折叠并用别针别出数千条丝带。然后全部免费分发。
In mid-May, I have this very foolish idea that we should be on the Tony Awards. We've left us approximately two weeks to achieve this. I'll convince everybody that this was not going to be disruptive, but rather something they should embrace. A number of visual aids members had Broadway connections. They haggled with the organizers of the Tony Awards and coaxed celebrity dressers into pinning the ribbons on their clients before the ceremony. And they got to work making new ribbons. Mark Hoppe's studio was mad, it was fabulous. We were distributing the more typically sized ribbons, but we thought,
在五月中旬，我有一个非常愚蠢的想法，觉得我们应该登上托尼奖的舞台。我们只剩下大约两周的时间来实现这个目标。我说服了每个人，这不会具有破坏性，反而应该是他们应该拥抱的东西。许多“视觉艾滋”成员拥有百老汇的人脉。他们与托尼奖组织者讨价还价，并说服名流造型师在典礼前将丝带别在客户的翻领上。他们开始制作新的丝带。马克·霍佩的工作室简直疯狂，太棒了。我们分发的是通常尺寸的丝带，但我们想，
oh, we're going to ruin everybody's dress and dinner jacket. So let's make them big and specific for the presenters. So the camera could like really capture them. The night of the show came June 7th, 1991. That night we all kind of went home and everybody was crossing their fingers because we didn't know. They didn't know if anyone would actually wear the ribbons. I mean, we handed all this stuff out and all these water supervisors and all these treasures are new.
哦，我们要把每个人的礼服和晚礼服都弄坏了。所以让我们为颁奖嘉宾制作大号且特殊的尺寸。这样镜头就能真正捕捉到它们。演出之夜来到了 1991年 6月 7日。那天晚上我们都回家了，每个人都在祈祷，因为我们不知道。他们不知道是否真的有人会佩戴丝带。我的意思是，我们把所有这些东西分发出去，所有这些水上主管和所有这些服装师都知道。
They said, sure, we'll see what we can do. Promise much, but we'll try. Tonight, live from the Minskov theater on Broadway the 1991 Tony Awards hosted by this year's Academy Award winner, a former Tony Award winner, Mr. Jeremy Irons. And Jeremy Irons walked out with a red ribbon on his lapel. The fact that he walked out wearing it was the most brilliant thing. I mean, I'm emotional and now because it was like, wow, you know, it worked. I found the full show on YouTube. Jeremy Earns is so handsome, the slick back hair and a big red ribbon on the left lapel at his black
他们说，当然，我们会看看能做些什么。不敢保证太多，但我们会试试。今晚，百老汇明斯科夫剧院现场直播 1991年托尼奖，由今年的奥斯卡奖得主、前托尼奖得主杰里米·艾恩斯先生主持。杰里米·艾恩斯走上台，翻领上别着一条红丝带。他戴着它走出来的举动是最绝妙的事情。我的意思是，我现在很激动，因为这就像是，哇，你知道，它成功了。我在 YouTube上找到了完整的节目。杰里米·艾恩斯太帅了，向后梳的头发，黑色西装
tux. The first winner of the night's this little girl, Daisy Egan, star of the secret garden. The first winner of the night's this little girl, Daisy Egan, star of the secret garden. I don't think I can talk. She's got this poofy sleeve black and white dress on, and a little red ribbon on her chest. Thank you. Then there's Kevin Spacey. Kevin Spacey lost in Yandex. He goes up to accept his award with a more medium-sized red ribbon. Thank you very much.
左翻领上别着一条大红丝带。当晚的第一个获奖者是这个小女孩，黛西·伊根，《秘密花园》的主演。当晚的第一个获奖者是这个小女孩，黛西·伊根，《秘密花园》的主演。我觉得我说不出话来。她穿着一件荷叶边袖的黑白连衣裙，胸前别着一条小红丝带。谢谢。接下来是凯文·史派西。凯文·史派西在《失去》中失利。他上台领奖时，别着一条中等大小的红丝带。非常感谢。
Next you see Penn and Teller wearing big red ribbons. By the end of the show I was paying more attention to the presenters not wearing ribbons, totally judging them for missing the memo. What you also noticed watching the Tonys is how new the awareness ribbon was. Everyone was wearing them in different ways. Some were looped, some were folded in sharp angles. Some of the ribbons have their ends spread wide like wings. But here's the crucial thing. No one explained the ribbons on air. Rumor has it the network
接下来你看到潘和泰勒戴着大红丝带。到节目结束时，我更多地关注那些没有佩戴丝带的颁奖嘉宾，在心里狠狠地评判他们错过了这个备忘录。观看托尼奖时你还会注意到，意识丝带是多么新颖。每个人佩戴它们的方式都不同。有些是环状的，有些折叠成锐角。有些丝带的两端像翅膀一样张开。但关键在于：没有任何人在节目中解释这些丝带。有传言说，如果他们这么做，电视台
threatened to go to commercial break if they did. Turns out this degree of mystery provided some incredibly good press. The one thing that was kind of exciting is the next day there was a little blurb in the newspaper that was like what was that red ribbon and it was everywhere at the Tony Awards. There was two days of print media wondering what this red ribbon was. So you know that really I think for us and for the red ribbon itself was just the point where it just exploded. Within days, the ribbon was stopping traffic.
威胁要插播商业广告。事实证明，这种神秘感带来了一些极其出色的宣传。让人有点兴奋的一件事是，第二天报纸上有一篇简短的报道，大致是那条红丝带有何玄机，它在托尼奖上随处可见。有两天的平面媒体都在猜测这条红丝带是什么。所以你知道，这真的对我们和红丝带本身来说，就是它彻底爆发的时刻。几天之内，这条丝带就引起了轰动。
We ran into this seemingly very successful businessman and his wife on the streets and he saw us wearing our ribbon and he was like, I saw that. I saw that on the Tony's, and he's like, that's about AIDS, isn't it? Isn't it? That's about AIDS, because no one actually said it. And I said, well, yes. And he's like, how do you get when I said,
我们在街上遇到了这个看上去非常成功的商人和他的妻子，他看到我们戴着丝带，就说，我看到了。我在托尼奖上看到了那个，他说，那是关于艾滋病的，对吧？是不是？那是关于艾滋病的，因为当时没有人真正说出来。我说，嗯，是的。然后他说，你是怎么弄到的？我说，
well, actually, we made them, it's our project. Anyway, he like peeled off $100 bill and gave it to us. When they found out what it was for, I think a lot of people really got on board and just were like, I need to start wearing a red ribbon. And it just really pushed it over into being kind of almost a, you know, just a much bigger symbol than it ever had been. And I think that we ever really thought it might be so quickly. The next stop for the ribbon was the Emmys, then the Oscars and the Grammy Awards, and
嗯，其实是我们自己做的，这是我们的项目。不管怎样，他掏出了一张 100美元的钞票递给了我们。当人们发现它是为了什么时，我想很多人都真正加入了进来，并且觉得，我需要开始佩戴一条红丝带。这真的把它推向了一个几乎可以说是一个比以往任何时候都大得多的符号，而且我想我们从来没有想过它会这么快。丝带的下一站是艾美奖，然后是奥斯卡奖和格莱美奖，而
the members of VisualAids continue to gather to make them. Cut, fold, and pin. We would be watching on TV, famous people wear our ribbons while we sat in the law huffed making ribbons together. Very meta, as they now say. In those days we said it would have been very pomem-o. School groups and church groups started contacting the visual aid artists, asking how they could start
“视觉艾滋”的成员们继续聚集在一起制作它们。切割、折叠和别别针。我们会一边在电视上看着名人们佩戴我们的丝带，一边坐在律所里气喘吁吁地一起制作丝带。正如他们现在所说的那样，非常元叙事。在那些日子里，我们会说这非常“后现代”（pomem-o）。学校团体和教会团体开始联系“视觉艾滋”艺术家，询问他们如何才能开始
their own ribbon project. And it just becomes this phenomenon, which we were surprised by. When did it start to feel like the ribbon was out of your hands? Like it was no longer visually seen? Well, probably by the end of 92, in terms of the introduction of like, you know, the bejeweled leathering back, crystal pave, red ribbon, et cetera. There were red ribbon diamond necklaces, red ribbon Christmas ornaments, red ribbon t-shirts.
他们自己的丝带项目。它就这样变成了一种现象，这让我们感到惊讶。什么时候开始觉得丝带已经不在你们的掌控之中了？就像它不再是从视觉上被看到的那样？嗯，大概到 92年底吧，随着各种设计的引入，你知道的，镶满珠宝的皮革衬底、水晶密镶的红丝带等等。出现了红丝带钻石项链、红丝带圣诞饰品、红丝带 T恤。
There were some of us that thought that visual aids should trademark it. And so that any time it's used, the money had to come back to visual aids. One of the reasons we didn't was that it would not have been embraced so willingly and so universally if we had. If everyone had to come and say, may I have permission to do this, it would have been in contrast to
我们当中有些人认为“视觉艾滋”应该为它注册商标。这样无论何时使用，资金都必须回流到“视觉艾滋”。我们没有这样做的一个原因，是如果那样的话，它就不会被如此自愿和普遍地接受。如果每个人都必须来问：“我可以获得这样做的许可吗？”，这就与
the spirit of the artwork. So yeah, I wish visual aids had a nickel for every ribbon petled in the world or ribbon object. Yes, that's after the fact. The Ribbon's Creators felt a backlash from other AIDS activists. At first, just wearing the ribbon felt like a radical act, publicly acknowledging that AIDS existed, that people were suffering, that you cared. But as the ribbon became more ubiquitous, some activists called wearing it, and easy out, a way to look like you cared about people with AIDS without actually doing anything to help people with AIDS.
艺术品的精神相违背了。所以，是的，我希望“视觉艾滋”能为世界上售出的每一条丝带或丝带物品得到五美分。是的，那是事后诸葛亮。丝带的创造者们感受到了来自其他艾滋病活动人士的强烈反对。起初，仅仅佩戴丝带就感觉像是一种激进的行为，公开承认艾滋病的存在，承认人们在受苦，承认你在乎。但随着丝带变得越来越无处不在，一些活动人士称佩戴它是一种轻松的解脱，是一种无需为帮助艾滋病患者做任何实际事情就能让自己看起来关心艾滋病患者的方式。
Basically the same criticisms that met the Livestrong bracelet and the Ice Bucket Challenge. But Mark Hopple says that's okay. What we wanted to do was create something that a mother in Michigan could wear on the lapel of her blouse. And you know, maybe her son was living in New York and living with AIDS and she wanted to do something. I think it was just, it was also a symbol that we created that somebody could wear and somebody might go up to them
基本上就是那些针对“自强手环”（Livestrong bracelet）和“冰桶挑战”（Ice Bucket Challenge）的批评。但马克·霍佩说没关系。我们想做的是创造一种东西，可以让密歇根的一位母亲别在她的衬衫翻领上。你知道，也许她的儿子住在纽约，身患艾滋病，而她想做点什么。我认为这只是一种我们创造的符号，别人可以佩戴它，然后可能会有人走过去对他们说
and say, what is that? Why are you wearing that red ribbon? And hopefully that person would say, here's why. The ribbon was doing its job. People were talking about AIDS. The New York Times declared 1992 the year of the ribbon. President Clinton set up the White House Office of National AIDS Policy, the National Institute of Health expanded its AIDS research, and the government funded the National HIV Epidemiology
这是什么？你为什么戴着那条红丝带？希望这个人会回答，原因如下。这条丝带正在发挥作用。人们在谈论艾滋病。《纽约时报》将 1992年宣布为“丝带之年”。克林顿总统成立了白宫国家艾滋病政策办公室，美国国立卫生研究院扩大了其艾滋病研究，政府资助了国家艾滋病流行病学
Study. Over time, the awareness ribbon has gotten so much attention for AIDS that more than 200 other causes by our last count now use a looped Awareness Ribbon as their symbol. Well it's interesting that, almost 25 years later, it's everywhere now in everybody's face and in different colors. There's the pink ribbon for breast cancer awareness, an indigo ribbon for bullying awareness, a teal ribbon for anxiety disorder awareness.
研究。随着时间的推移，“意识丝带”因艾滋病而获得了如此多的关注，据我们最新统计，现在有 200多个其他事业也使用环状的“意识丝带”作为他们的标志。有趣的是，大约 25年后，它现在无处不在，出现在每个人的眼前，而且有不同的颜色。有用于乳腺癌意识的粉红丝带，用于欺凌意识的靛蓝丝带，用于焦虑症意识的水鸭蓝丝带。
Actually, the teal ribbon is also used for ovarian cancer awareness, threat syndrome awareness, tsunami victim awareness. There are more causes that want ribbons than there are colors of ribbon. And the ribbons ubiquity eventually reached the point of parity. When the band Death Cab procuredi wore light blue ribbons at the Grammys in 2009, people wondered, was it about secondhand smoke awareness or Adreno cortical carcinoma awareness?
事实上，水鸭蓝丝带也被用于卵巢癌意识、抽动秽语综合征意识、海啸受害者意识。想要丝带的事业比丝带的颜色还要多。而丝带的无处不在最终达到了饱和点。当乐团 Death Cab for Cutie在 2009年格莱美奖上佩戴浅蓝色丝带时，人们纳闷，这是为了二手烟意识还是肾上腺皮质癌意识？
It turns out Death Cab procuredi had started their own cause, auto-tune abuse awareness. Yeah. You know, on 7th Avenue, you'd call that a knockoff elsewhere. You'd call it a rip off. I think it's great that people took that simple little ribbon with a pin and made it their own, you know, and used it for whatever cause they were fighting. I'm totally fine with that and I think, you know, it's there for people to use. In whatever way they want to and however they want to get a message out. I think the thing that really captures my imagination when I look at it is that it's such a perfect form.
原来 Death Cab for Cutie 发起了他们自己的事业，即“电音修音滥用意识”（auto-tune abuse awareness）。是的。你知道的，在第七大道，你会称那为山寨货，在别处，你会称之为剽窃。我觉得人们能把那个带别针的简单小丝带拿来并使其成为他们自己的东西，你知道的，并把它用于他们正在为之奋斗的任何事业，这真是太棒了。我完全可以接受，而且我认为，你知道，它是供人们使用的。以他们想要的任何方式，以及他们想要传达信息的任何方式。我认为当我看着它时，真正抓住我想象力的是它是一个如此完美的形态。
It's beautiful and economic in terms of its design and that is the best kind of design. It's beautiful and economic in terms of its design, and that is the best kind of design. That's Michelle Miller Fisher. She's a curatorial assistant at the architecture and design department at the Museum of Modern Art, the Momma. In this last month, she helped make the Red Aids ribbon
它在设计上既美观又经济，这就是最好的设计。它在设计上既美观又经济，这就是最好的设计。那是米歇尔·米勒·费舍尔（Michelle Miller Fisher）。她是现代艺术博物馆（MoMA）建筑与设计部的策展助理。就在上个月，她协助将红色艾滋丝带
an official part of the museum's collection. She remembers first seeing the ribbon as a kid in England in the 90s. The very first time I saw it, I realized that advocacy and passion, even understanding it as a very young child, could be imbued in a very simple design. The Momma has in its collection one of the hand-cut visual aids ribbons pinned to an original ribbon project hand out explaining its meaning. I love the fact that I can see where someone has cut this, and so I wonder whether this was someone's like 50th ribbon of the day or 100th ribbon of the day.
列为该博物馆收藏的官方藏品。她还记得 90年代在英国作为一个孩子第一次看到丝带的情景。我第一次看到它时，我意识到倡导和热情，即使作为一个非常小的孩子也能理解，可以融入到一个非常简单的设计中。MoMA 的收藏中有一条手剪的“视觉艾滋”丝带，别在一份解释其含义的原始丝带项目宣传单上。我喜欢这样一个事实，即我可以看到有人剪过它的痕迹，所以我很好奇这是否是某人当天的第 50 条丝带或第 100 条丝带。
The Momma plans to have the ribbon out on display in the next year. I will always think it's relevant. My cobble again. Because, you know, aids is still with us. It's still out there and we still have to be aware of it and we still have to raise money and we still have to fight it and we still have to care for people and so on and so forth. Now AIDS isn't the killer that it used to be, at least in the US, but that doesn't mean the disease is gone. The number of people living with HIV in the United States is now higher than ever before.
MoMA 计划在明年将这条丝带公开发布展出。我将永远认为它是相关的。又是科布尔。因为，你知道，艾滋病仍然伴随着我们。它依然存在，我们仍然需要意识到它，我们仍然需要筹集资金，我们仍然需要与之抗争，我们仍然需要关怀他人，等等。现在艾滋病已经不像以前那样致命了，至少在美国是这样，但这并不意味着这种疾病已经消失。美国感染艾滋病毒的人数现在比以往任何时候都要高。
Patrick O'Connor also says he'll keep wearing his AIDS awareness ribbons. Back at his apartment, he showed me the ribbons in his wardrobe. Sure they're on stuff still. There must be 30 ribbons there I feel. Yeah, they're probably a heck of a hundred and there somewhere. He doesn't even take them off when he washes his shirts and just keeps them pinned on. Is there anything I haven't asked you about the ribbon? You don't need to ask? Well, you didn't ask if we had fun.
帕特里克·奥康纳（注：应为奥康奈尔）也表示他会继续佩戴他的艾滋病意识丝带。回到他的公寓里，他向我展示了他衣柜里的丝带。当然它们还挂在东西上。我觉得那里一定有 30 条丝带。是的，那里大概有一百多条吧。他甚至在洗衬衫时都不把它们取下来，而是让它们一直别在上面。关于丝带，有什么我没问你的吗？你不需要问吗？嗯，你没有问我们是否过得开心。
And we did. Bizarrely, we had fun. I'm telling you, fun. Give my regards to Broadway. Remember me to help square. Tell all the folks on 40 seconds, say that I will soon be there. Tell them that I'm yearning to mingle with the old times wrong. Give my regards to all Broadway and say that I'll be there along. Say hello to Deerone Coney High. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Audrey Quinn with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan,
而我们确实很开心。奇怪的是，我们过得很开心。我告诉你，真的很开心。向百老汇问好。代我向时代广场问好。告诉 42街上的所有人，说我很快就会去那里。告诉他们我渴望重温旧梦。向整个百老汇问好，并说我很快就会去。向科尼岛亲爱的问好。本周的 99% Invisible 由奥黛丽·奎因（Audrey Quinn）与凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、
Avery Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxan, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. The inspiration for this story came from WHYWISE, the pulse where you can also hear Audrey's story about the history of the breast cancer ribbon will link to the pulse on our website. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter and you can follow me at Roman Mars if you want to watch me devolve over the week as my wife is away. We also have a Tumblr with cool stuff every single day, but more info on this story and
艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Trouffleman）以及我罗曼·马斯共同制作。我们是旧金山 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的一家建筑与室内设计公司 Arxan 的办公室里制作。这个故事的灵感来自 WHYWISE，在这个播客中你还可以听到奥黛丽关于乳腺癌丝带历史的故事，我们将在网站上提供该播客的链接。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并点赞这个节目。我们都在 Twitter 上，如果你想看我在妻子不在家的一周里情绪逐渐崩溃，可以关注我 @Roman Mars。我们还有一个每天都有酷炫内容的 Tumblr，关于这个故事的更多信息和
the entire 99PI catalog can be found at 99pr.org. Radio to be on. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
整个 99PI 的节目目录可以在 99pi.org 上找到。Radio to be on。来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。